[Music]
from the studio that cut jk rowling from
the harry potter special cut johnny depp
from this movie cut zack snyder from
justice league wants to cut amber heard
from aquaman 2
and is somehow cutting ezra miller from
the flash as we speak comes the third of
five planned films and i'm sure warners
will honor that instead of changing
their minds and cutting the last two
entirely
uh yeah we're not getting another harry
potter movie for a long time
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore
journey to magical 1930s germany for
more of what the fantastic beasts movies
have always been about magic politics
well officially the ministry takes no
position unofficially my money's on
santos magic bureaucracy
and magic black site prisons and
execution chambers
because when a fantastic beast appears
in this movie they kill its mom
the baby's throat
and bleed the childlike wonder from this
franchise like a dead deer in a
necromancer's jacuzzi
every soft boy and small bean's favorite
character is back newt's commander who's
so unnecessary to the story they make an
animal pick the next president so he has
a reason to stick around you're all
right his main love interest tina is not
bad tina's been promoted she's uh very
very busy because trans rights are human
rights also returning is jacob and his
permanent office
[Music]
credence who's dying of i don't know
morbius disease queenie who spends the
entire film looking like she has a sharp
rock in her shoe but doesn't want to
yo-cut and ruin the take
[Music]
and a bunch more characters who may or
may not be carryovers from the last film
i mean almost none of us are of course
no matter how good of a person one tries
to be was she the last one i feel like
i'd remember that accent put yourself in
danger to save a perfect stranger
strap in for the story of a magic
friendship bracelet that stops
dumbledore from fighting his high school
sweetheart i was in love with you that's
right dumbledore's out he's proud he
used to be a pureblood fanatic who vowed
to do a genocide
it was you who said we could reshape the
world also he has no friends he probably
killed his sister abandon his nephew and
his remaining family hates him
real as he takes on his old play colin
fair
johnny dear
mads mickelson's grindelwald a guy who
hates the human race but loves to cup a
face
that's twice you failed me using a plan
that's hard to follow by design see if
we hope to defeat him then our best hope
is to confuse him the fact that
everything didn't go
precisely the plan was precisely the
plan resulting in the franchise's latest
climactic goo on goo final duel only the
wizard with the most potent goo can win
ready set
so sit through the final installment of
the series who lived even though no one
wanted it to anymore as jk rowling runs
out of fans runs out of nostalgia to
milk three points to hufflepuff oh yay
he said the thing and runs out of new
ideas except for her one move where she
dramatically reveals more sibling stuff
you murdered his sister dumbledore has a
brother twins
he had twins my sister
was an obscurian she's my brother she's
my sister she's my brother and my sister
don't tell jk rowling
starring
dr dos little
jude lawfully good hannibal lecturer
lovable mug
yes queenie
kamakamakama kamakama the magician
i used to ship him now i'm not so sure
one dope queen
assistant to the regionals commander
the flush crab people crap people and
the mexican pizza had taco bell
astonishing
never something that looks so rapid and
tasted so delicious
hairy politics and the chillin of a
villain
you don't need a magic spell to erase
the memories of these characters dude
the movies did that all on their own
commands primary ignition
be running up that road be running up
that hill be running up that building
no problems
i say whatever people tell me to on
youtube do you love me now father do you
why won't you love me